seven in order to fix the economy we  have to first unlock our brain ten one  year ago my IQ was at 80. today it is at  nearly a hundred how look some people  think everything that matters is  exercise I think other things matter too  here are some of my favorite books how  to have sex for the first time the alpha  male's guide to winning at slot machine  I'm afraid of women I learned how to  take care of myself through self-help  grind can sometimes be painful it's good  but it  it can be painful it started snowing the  other day and I was struck by the  incredible beauty of nature some days I  just need to stand in my garage to get  away from everything you know it's  peaceful in there I don't have to grind  I don't have to clean my room in the  garage I could just  be me